we've had so much chest this year and
it's almost a finish line with London
finals coming up what does it take to
make it to the grand chester finals well
this year has actually been very
interesting for all the top players this
has been a very fascinating year it's
one of a kind because there's just so
many Germans left and right I don't know
there's a specific quality for the tour
as opposed to other tournaments I mean
partially it's also where you get you
know good results obviously I have a
reasonable shot but there's still a
tournament to play so I'll focus on that
I'm very glad I got the opportunity this
time to play in the full tour because I
see that with my colleagues you know
they gain experience playing this
particular this time control and also
this routine of the rapid embrace and
they if they have so much experience
playing this year after year in
Grantchester and I see they are getting
better at itself to the bridge results
in the United States now I am very close
to the London final I'm qualified but
I'm not completely certain as I could be
but I'm still very very satisfied with
my play in this tour I was in very good
shape in United States and I prayed
fearlessly I gained more confidence so
that made me stronger
I usually have one event where I do
really badly like I'm totally off
without fail to be here and I'd finished
last place it's hard to compete against
the likes of Magnus ending were really
consistent normally in a tournament like
this I would say that well I'm here I
don't really have too much to to play
for but I feel like I'm super motivated
that I'm not gonna hold back I'm not
gonna think that I'm going to coast
since I'm already profile for for London
and I'm gonna try and spoil the other
guys chances as marshal sometime